-Thank you very much, everyone!
Thank you!
On a Friday!
That's some Friday love
right there.
Thank you. Welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Let's get to the news
and jokes.
Well, guys, everyone's
still talking about
last night's
presidential debate.
But based on the early ratings,
it had about 7 million fewer
viewers than the first one.
It's not that 7 million people
chose not to watch.
It's that after the first
debate, they left the country.
[ Laughter ]
Based on some snap polls,
Trump won the debate
by 98% to 2%.
That's according to
the fair polling site,
guntotingeagle.com.
[ Laughter ]
But this is interesting.
The Trump campaign announced
that yesterday was their biggest
online fundraising day ever,
pulling in $26 million.
Wow, he really has the
bird-killing wind at his back.
Yep, Trump raised $26 million.
Today he was like,
"Spend the million on TV ads,
put the rest in my
Chinese bank account."
[ Laughter ]
Did you see this?
Two of Trump's guests last night
were Kid Rock
and golfer John Daly.
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
They look great.
I think they bought those
clothes at QAnon Members Only.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Trump wanted Kid Rock's
support, mostly because
he thinks Kid Rock is
Dwayne Johnson's son.
[ Laughter ]
I shouldn't make fun of them.
In 2024,
that's going to be
the Republican ticket.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, after the debate,
Donald Trump Jr.
went on Fox News and he was
really pumped
about his dad's performance.
I mean, really pumped.
Watch this.
-The media runs right away.
It's Russian disinformation.
There's literally zero evidence
that it's Russian
disinformation.
The Director of National
Intelligence said --
and by the way, more
importantly, the FBI said it,
and I don't say that because
I think the FBI has more
credibility, I say that because
it's pretty clear that the FBI
has done whatever they possibly
could to hurt Donald Trump.
So if they're even coming out
and saying this,
meaning the upper levels
of the FBI.
The door kickers love us,
not so much the bureaucrats
at the top.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Was he double parked
or something?
[ Laughter ]
Looks like someone's been
dipping into Daddy's
nuclear-powered steroids.
He sounds like a kindergartner
who can't wait to tell you
about his day.
And then -- and then --
and then we finger painted,
and then we ate lunch,
and then we played outside,
and then we -- and then
we stuck up for Russia,
and then --
I didn't know if I was
watching "Hannity"
or an episode of "Narcos."
[ Laughter ]
In six months, Don Jr.'s
going to be auctioning off
unclaimed storage units.
[ Laughter ]
That was a good deep cut.
He sounds like the guy who reads
the side effects
on the end of
a Zoloft commercial.
[ Rapid indistinct talking ]
Sounded like every conversation
that's ever happened at a rave.
[ Laughter ]
Well, with less than two weeks
until the election,
the President is campaigning
as much as he can.
Take a look.
-President Trump,
he is about to begin a whirlwind
weekend of campaigning.
He'll be heading down South for
campaign events in the villages,
then a rally tonight in the
Panhandle and Pensacola.
He'll be staying overnight
in Florida, getting a chance
to early vote tomorrow.
He'll be holding rallies this
weekend in places like
North Carolina, Ohio,
and Wisconsin.
And then Sunday, another rally
in New Hampshire.
-He's starting to turn
into that band where
you're just like,
"Weren't they just here?"
[ Laughter ]
The rallies aren't
really changing
Trump's approval rating.
However, the coronavirus numbers
are through the roof.
[ Laughter and ohhs ]
Trump hasn't worked this hard
since he had to be quiet
for two minutes at the debate
last night.
[ Laughter ]
This is pretty crazy.
A security researcher claims
that he was able to
get into Trump's Twitter account
by guessing his password.
Check out what it was.
-A Dutch security researcher
was able to access
President Trump's
Twitter account last week
by guessing his password,
maga2020!
[ Laughter ]
-If you're worried about
the nuclear codes, don't be.
That password is maga2020!!
with two exclamation points.
[ Laughter ]
Well, another big story is
early voting.
Millions of Americans
are doing it,
and today one of them
was Mike Pence.
Here he is casting his ballot
in Indiana.
Yep, the Pences were excited.
They haven't done a joint
thumbs up since their honeymoon.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"What do you think?"
"All right."
Some news from overseas.
-Okay.
Never mind.
-Some news from overseas.
-[ Laughs ]
-North Korea has ordered
a lockdown over concerns that
yellow dust from China could
spread the coronavirus.
Kim Jong-Un made
the announcement,
along with his infectious
disease expert,
Dr. Kim Jong-Fauci.
[ Laughter ]
If the lockdown wasn't
bad enough,
Kim Jong-Un is now
forcing everyone
to do a Zoom happy hour.
[ Sighs ]
Gosh.
If you think quarantine
in America is bad,
over in North Korea, the only
thing they have on Netflix
is "Emily in Pyongyang."
[ Laughter ]
-Nice one.
-You can give me a thing.
-I got it.
-Yeah, yeah.
It's just a mental -- it's
a silent [imitates rimshot].
-I got it.
-It's alright.
[ Rimshot ]
No, no. That's right.
That's hacky. I know.
You don't want to do that.
-I take it back.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-[ Imitates reverse speaking ]
-Oh, he took it back.
-Yeah.
-Oh, my God.
[ Applause ]
-He actually reversed
himself.
He reversed himself.
That was awesome.
[ Imitates reverse speaking ]
Hey, did you see last night
the New York Giants
were playing...some team.
-Who?
-[ Groaning ]
-It doesn't matter, right?
The Philadelphia Eagles.
-Yeah.
[ Rimshot ]
-And Giants quarterback
Daniel Jones tried running
for an 88-yard touchdown.
Let's see how that went.
-From the 12. Jones keeps.
Gets a block.
Takes off, and he is gone!
Trying to stay upright,
and he trips!
[ Gasping ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter ]
-That felt like re-watching
the last season
of "Game of Thrones."
Like, yes, yes...aw!
[ Laughter ]
Well, the holidays
are coming up,
and Southwest Airlines just made
a big announcement
about their flights.
Take a look.
-Southwest Airlines is
dropping a pandemic policy
that provided more social
distancing on flights.
It will no longer keep
middle seats empty,
starting December 1st.
Southwest says air filtering
and masks
have created healthy
environments aboard planes.
-Come on.
It's Southwest.
The whole plane is
a middle seat.
[ Laughter ]
You actually don't have
to worry,
because even the coronavirus
doesn't want anything to do
with the middle seat on
Southwest.
The middle seat on Southwest.
I'd rather be on lockdown
in North Korea.
Pretty sure the only in-flight
entertainment they have
on Southwest is
"Emily in Pyongyang."
[ Laughter ]
[ Scattered applause ]
And finally, Guinness
is about to unveil
its newest product.
Let's see what it is.
-Guinness launching its
first-ever non-alcoholic beer.
It's called Guinness Zero.
It took the company four years
to re-create the same taste
as its original stout
without the alcohol.
-If you order that
in Ireland,
you're marched through
town while everyone throws
rotten vegetables at you.
"Shame, shame!"
[ Laughter ]
Guinness without booze?
Here's how Irish people
are reacting.
-Come on!
-There you go.